we are all to some degree in time and we  are all to some degree in eternity and  to the degree that we are in eternity we  behave correctly and have right activity  and right perception and these  psychedelics enhance this involvement  with the totality of everything that's  why it is not naive to suggest that  issues like the nuclear gridlock and all  these other terminal problems that we  have could be overcome if people would  by any means try to come into a tenement  with the notion of unity in time and  space as the species and the planet and  solar systemin and I think this is the  evolving core idea which will either  save us or the absence of its evolution  will be our ruin the idea of unity and  interrelatedness  [Music]